the first u.s. death from the
coronavirus happened much earlier than
previously thought
until now the first known victim was
reported to have died in Washington
State on February 29th but new testing
reveals that someone actually died of
the virus in California three weeks
earlier on February 6 today the reported
national death toll is more than 45,000
people yeah Gail the actual toll may be
higher because many people are never
able to get tested because of shortages
of kids and now we know health care
workers and first responders will soon
receive the first FDA authorized at-home
test and we have FDA Commissioner dr.
Stephen Hahn joining us now to tell us
more dr. Hahn good morning Americans are
sitting at home right now and they're
wondering two things when can I get back
to work and can I do it safely this
at-home test
tell us about it where does it fit into
the bigger puzzle of testing which seems
so important to doing those two things
return to normalcy returning to the
economy working as usual
good morning Anthony thank you for
having me so this new test is an at-home
collection test for a diagnostic that is
a test that would diagnose the presence
of the Cova 19 by a virus and this is a
test where it's going to focus lab core
this company has developed this is going
to focus first on frontline health care
workers and first responders those with
symptoms can go online and fill out a
questionnaire the questionnaire will be
reviewed by a healthcare professional a
licensed physician and if appropriate
and consistent with the CDC guidelines a
package will be sent overnight with a
swab and a tube it's very easy and safe
to perform our data show that it's as
accurate as having it performed in the
doctor's office or in a clinic they can
perform the tests put it in the tube of
saline and overnight it back to the lab
and then get the results they're after
from lab quarter well it sounds like
good news dr. Han let's talk about how
it fits into the bigger picture I was
looking at the testing data and the US
has been stuck at below 200,000 tests
per day that is at least half as many we
need to double that pace maybe even
triple it to reopen safely according to
some experts and their estimates what
are we doing to close that gap is
at home test part of it the at-home test
is certainly part of it and FDA has
issued 59 emergency use authorization
for tests four of which of the antibody
tests and the rest of the diagnostic
tests we have over 300 developers who
are working with us to continue to
expand that capacity the other thing
that it's really important to know and
this has been mentioned several times
and we've had calls with the governor's
about it there is unlocked capacity in
the country we're working very closely
with the governors and the state public
health officials to make sure that the
adequate supplies and the information
about where those tests are available
are made known to folks so that they can
actually unlock that capacity and we
believe that based upon that information
that we could double the number of tests
that are done in a very short period of
time can you tell us doctor Han what a
very short period of time is right now
every day counts people want to get back
to work if we need to double the number
of tests that we're doing how soon can
we do that can you give us a date sure I
mean you've seen dr. Burks and dr. fat
you talked about this on the podium that
could be done this week if the
appropriate identification occurs at the
state level and then the supplies are
there for them and so this is every day
working with the states unlocking that
capacity getting the supplies where
they're needed and actually informing
the state public health officials about
what alternative supplies are available
and and we've issued a number of
flexible policies to allow different
swabs and different agents to be
available and we are disseminating that
information very quickly to the states
dr. Han let's talk about something that
dr. Redfield at the CDC said yesterday
to the Washington Post we could see a
second wave of the corona virus next
winter it could make this way pale by
comparison do you agree with his
assessment are you worried about that
second wave I think that it's certainly
a possibility and the whole task for a
set of doctors is concerned about the
second wave and a dr. red fields concern
is that there also might be flu at the
same time but that's why we have built
into the plan the surveillance
mechanisms to look for the respiratory
illnesses and then to do the appropriate
tests
singing at that time that's going to be
a critical part of the reopening plan to
allow us to move forward and dr. Hine
just a simple yes or no because I have
to go here the timetable for a vaccine
which would be really a game-changer
last we checked in with you is about a
year off that would be March of 2021 is
that still the case
still the case that the estimate is
March but we're really trying to
accelerate the efforts and we will try
for sooner sir dr. Hahn a lot of people
counting on you we thank you for
spending a few minutes with us today
thank you very much